Captain Marvel ties into the MCU due to
its inclusion of the tesseract the
mystical Cosmic Cube that contains the
space stone this linchpin of the Marvel
movie franchise has appeared in several
movies and those who've seen Captain
Marvel may leave theaters scratching
their head as to where exactly it plays
into the overall arc of the movies so
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the tesseract as well as its
entire timeline from beginning to end
this is full spoilers ahead for every
MCU movie so if you aren't fully up to
speed with Captain Marvel then I highly
suggest that you turn off now with that
out the way I'm definition and welcome
to the channel where I explain it so you
don't have to in Captain America the
First Avenger the tesseract makes its
first appearance in the timeline Johann
Schmidt aka the Red Skull is searching
for the mystical item and discovers it
locked away in a secret muriel he states
that it was the jewel of Odin's treasure
room on Asgard so how exactly did it get
to our planet well we've never had this
confirmed for sure but it seems like it
was placed on earth for protection much
in the same way that the aether was
endure the dark world on another planet
to keep it out of the wrong hands the
Red Skull wanted to channel the
tesseract power into weapons but after
some intervention by the Allies in
Captain America he attempted to hold it
in his hands blasted across the galaxy
from the power of the space stone that
was harnessed within the cube then ended
up in the ocean where it was picked up
by Howard Stark from here ends up at
shield which is when stark and the other
members of the team begin project
Pegasus which plays heavily into Captain
Marvel dr. Wendy Lawson aka Marvel tried
to harness the power of the tesseract
and a top secret base in the mojave
desert in order to help the scrolls
achieve Lightspeed technology so that
they could outrun the cream on her
cloaked orbital Bay she hides the
tesseract before returning to earth to
carry out the experiment that would give
Captain Marvel her powers were Marvel
journeys to the base in the film
goosed the cat or should I say fluke in
swallows the cube before coughing it up
in Nick Fury's office in the
post-credits scene of the film here it
remains at the base in the Mojave
until it makes its next appearance in
the post-credits scene of Thor that
shows dr. Erik Selvig under the
influence of Loki Loki uses Selvig as a
puppet to open a doorway with the stone
which is when we get to its next
appearance in The Avengers in the
Avengers Loki shows up levels the base
from Captain Marvel and makes off with
the stone to allow the Chitauri invasion
to begin on earth it appears that the
tesseract goes dormant from time to time
as the introduction of the film states
that it has awakened and that the
Chitauri ally
aka Loki knows its inner workings the
avengers managed to stop the guard by
the end of the film and that is when the
tesseract is taken back to Asgard where
it remains in Odin's treasure room once
more and tell Thor Ragnarok in Thor
Ragnarok on his way out of the doomed
kingdom of god Loki grabs a stone and
hides it using his magic in the end
credits scene we see that as his ship
show up and invade the vessel and from
here it's taken by Thanos who crushes
the cube and takes the stone out uniting
it with the other Infinity stones in the
foam in order to carry out the snap from
then on the stone remains in the
gauntlet which is then cast aside upon
the completion of the NASA's mission
whilst Avengers endgame hasn't seen
release yet behind-the-scenes footage
shows that the cube may once again be
making an appearance so it would be
great to see a plane to that movie
somehow and that's everything you need
to know about the timeline of the
tesseract so far and how it came to be
in shields possession at the end of
Captain Marvel if you have any other
insight into the stone then make sure
you comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of Captain marbles ending and
post credits scenes which would be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition that you've been
the best and not seen
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]